so the the process for voice acting for
games can vary there are different not
styles but but different requirements so
there's performance capture which means
that you're in the suit with the funny
balls on it you know what's called a
volume and you're acting as if you're in
a theatre in the round so it's your your
facial performance and your your
physical performance is being captured
by multiple cameras around the volume
but you're having to emote and project
in such a way that it's as if you're
doing a small a small theatre setting
just because you need your your facial
expressions to show up and if you're
being too subtle then it's hard for
animators to be able to do anything with
that when they get the final footage so
there's that which is more I guess
closer to what you might think of an on
camera set being like where you have to
memorize your lines and you're working
with other actors directly generally at
least in my experience
motion capture is only used for
cutscenes and games but your your vocal
performance is captured on the day in
that moment but then separately and then
for some games you never do performance
capture but also separately you have to
do some booth time so that's kind of
when people think about the new game
voice acting that's probably more what
they think of which is you're in a booth
in isolation and you have a director and
a sound engineer and maybe you know the
dev or - either in person or on skype
with you and the script in front of you
and you're sometimes you're cold reading
which means you've never seen the script
before and you're reading the line for
the first time and performing it at the
same time sometimes you do get a script
beforehand but very rarely does that
happen with video games sometimes you
may not even know what character you're
playing sometimes you may not know what
game you're in so the skills that you
sort of need to have are the ability to
come in again be able to cold read so to
be able to read something in performance
in the same moment and also to be able
to sort of formulate a character fairly
quickly there have been some games where
I've had to come in and play three
different characters and sort of
on the spot you have to find ways to
differentiate your voice and your
attitude to make them feel distinct from
one another and all of that sort of
stuff now that there's a strictly
improvisational quality to it but so
that sort of flexibility is necessary
because you don't get a lot of prep time
often yeah I think so I think I it's
interesting I think I became a better
actor through our experience on
Uncharted because there was such good
actors that we worked with and you had
to show up and bring your game I mean
honestly I think yeah yeah he was really
really special and me just to be around
that that group to work with those
people have you know I remember reading
Gordon's book you know one of my
favorite things that I tell people get
his book that he said every after every
audition the best thing to do is set up
something have a something to look
forward to
after an audition so you forget about it
and I always thought that was great like
so the best party date doesn't have to
be that in audition that you're you know
you're really sweating over you know
just you're gonna meet some friends
you're gonna go do something fun and
it's true it's it really takes a lot of
the pressure off and you know there's
always going to be another audition you
know you know that's it's a little
disconcerting there you go you and the
moving trucks are at the house they're
they packed up everything when we start
getting old I know I know I know it
feels like they're putting your hat on
you and pushing you out the door like
going home but you can't stay but I got
a stay here I got stuff to pay for thank
God got a go
not that specifically I just mean and uh
sort of being my understanding being
feted I know te D I know what it means
no there's there's a portion I didn't
want to make you offended so for me
personally and all of my voiceover
experiences I usually don't have a
script prior to coming into the session
because it's all signing non-disclosure
agreements and every
usually very much under wraps so you
kind of just go in with a deep sense of
who the character is and who you felt
who she or he was when you auditioned
for them I usually like to make mental
notes about where did their voice sit
inside my chest where did where did I
feel them so then you go into the
session you usually get the script right
when you get there and they're setting
up the booth and usually it ends up
being four-hour sessions you're working
with the with the creative directors and
the creative team and they're pulling
out the best performance my favorite
part is always getting to throw in
ad-libs getting to play around with
stuff because sometimes you think
something's gonna work sometimes you
think oh this is exactly how it's gonna
be and then a curveball gets thrown at
you or you throw a curveball at the
creative team and then it becomes kind
of very collaborative in that sense
Firewatch all came from the walking dead
so I met Sean and Jake as I mentioned
working on the walking dead and Sean
reached out to me shortly after season 1
had wrapped and he said you know I've
left telltale I'm writing a new game
with a female protagonist are you in and
as an actor that is the greatest call to
get and I said yeah of course I said yes
and but it was you know a good two years
then until we actually kind of got down
to the Nitty Gritty of recording and of
course you know I went through the whole
range of emotion at that point if I go
have I been replaced have they found
someone else am I still in the running
is I still gonna be me you know all the
self-doubt that we go through as actors
and they had me record a sample track
back when her name was Alice and and we
did you know kind of a test run for them
so that they could hear how I would be
as her and then they went through their
process of finding Henry which was for
them quite arduous they they auditioned
several people just didn't quite fit the
bill and and they couldn't find who they
wanted and then rich Sommer was talking
with one of the Camposanto guys on a
tabletop game Twitter feed and he was
like hey I'd like to audition and they
were like oh okay and he just nailed it
so from there we started recording what
they did which was so wonderful as an
app
was they let me be in my home studio and
rich was in his home studio and Shawn
would Skype us in together and we would
have actual conversations actual
dialogue which as video game voice
actors we typically record and avoid we
might have a director who knows what
they're talking about we might not but
we never get to interact with the other
actors the other characters in the scene
and so to have this game that really
hinges upon believable dialogue be a
dialogue it was game changing pun
intended there is this huge like you
know realm of possibilities of because
you've got to think of the player I
think there's a lot of you know you've
got to really think of you know the
player choices and you've got to be able
to perform you know with the same
intensity depending on what the player
chooses and so you know there's a lot
more kind of there's a lot more stories
you know there's a lot more branching
off whereas you know where's film and TV
is quite linear you know video game it's
very much like a tree it could branch
down this way it could branch the other
way or you know so you've got all these
other choices that you've got to play
with and and it's a challenge it is a
challenge and but at the same time it's
so much fun you know so it is so
liberating because it is like it is that
it goes back to that feeling of okay
let's imagine that we are over here or
let's imagine we made this choice so
you've got all these different things to
play with personally I would really say
know what makes your voice special and
know what makes you special because at
the end of the day there are so many
there's so many I meet so many people
trying to get into voiceover and I
personally and they always ask me they
always actually had a few people ask me
for advice and I always talk about like
training is so important continuing your
vocal training making sure you're
healthy making sure you're strong I
always make sure to warm up before every
audition before every single session
because at the end of the day your voice
for voice acting is your instrument it's
the only way you can create your art and
then again find what makes you special I
found a great nation voicing young girls
they usually voice teenagers to
seven-year-old so know know what you do
best and attack it and go after it
it's not an overnight thing it's not
something that happens easily it takes a
lot of time and often a lot of money to
finally get an agent and start getting
great auditions and just keep working
find a coach find a reputable coach
someone who is not going to take your
money and promised you a demo at the end
of it work with somebody who has a great
reputation in the industry and continue
to work with them and then when they
tell you that maybe you're ready find
someone else to work with it's the best
thing in the world the one thing that's
kind of that I've tried to really do is
just focus on my own journey not compare
myself to other you know and my peers
and just try and just do what I love and
kind of keep that love going and keep
fighting and keep going because it is
tough it's it's me you know there's the
I could be working now I could be doing
these great interviews now and then I
could you know in a month's time I'd be
at home to live my films probably
playing my game but like it's like it's
a you know it can shift and change so
quickly but I think it there is that if
you really want to do it and you know
you can you really feel like this is
this is this is for me just keep going
it'll happen it will happen because you
know the more you kind of give off to
the universe it will give it back in
some way shape and form primarily the
most important thing is is to be a good
actor really I mean you know we talk you
know we talk about or people think about
voice acting being able being able to
make a lot of different funny voices or
having a really great handle on
different accents and while that's all
super useful it doesn't really matter
unless you have trained in the craft of
acting also something I didn't know when
I was starting out but I came you know a
friend sort of who was sort of mentoring
me told me was that you often get booked
on your natural voice anyway so there
are some people that are like the swiss
army voice actors that can come in and
do like 70 different voices all sound
different but many of us will just get
booked on our natural voices so the
thing that's really carrying you is your
acting abilities so studying the craft
and making sure that you're keeping up
on that is the most important thing I
think and then as far as breaking in
it's sort of the answer no one likes to
hear is that there's no set
but I think developing your craft and
making sure that you are staying on top
of your skill set and developing your
skill set is important so when
opportunities do show up you can meet
them with your best self you know I also
know people that you know will take
classes and they've gotten agents that
way or it may be booked some gigs
because often people you know agents
will conduct voice acting classes or
video game directors who will cast games
will sometimes do it so that's a good
way of meeting people that are in the
industry
yeah really I mean focusing on your
acting and then knowing that there are
certain skills that are necessary like
cold reading you can practice that or
take classes for that kind of thing and
and play games honestly so you know you
kind of know what is required to you I
think an actor's job is to deliver
performance I don't care if it's on a
stage with the live audience or a
microphone or a camera you have to
deliver that performance that's what
like that's that Amy's talking about
that athletic background it's like you
go out there and pitch go out there and
throw do your job and it doesn't change
my process I just want to go on deliver
an honest true performance and and
hopefully and have a good time in the
process you know mostly so you can get
hired again people that but with the
technology I think it just it just helps
everything you know good acting is when
you're settling you don't remember the
early early times when motion motion
captures started it was called motion
capture because they had people in the
development offices or stunt people and
you'd be like hey you and they'd be
doing these mom and then you had the
voice to that you're going why what is
he and then you try to go hey you what's
up and it's just these big histrionics
you're thinking what so to be able to
when they when they devolved into and
you know give Andy Serkis a lot of
credit for the fact that he brought it
to the forefront of what
is right yeah any really you know people
started recognizing it as what it is and
the funny thing is I games have been
doing it for years and now it but it got
its attention I don't care how it got
its attention it became more accepted
more valid you know and like you said
people took it as it's it's pure acting
it's it's the closest thing it's digital
theater it's we did those scenes with
uncharted or Last of Us I mean where
you're having heavy scenes with another
actor it's not just a voice performance
and now with the cameras and the
headgear and the markers on the face
every nuance so you you're more if
you're asking technically wise I think
it's you you're much more it's much more
on camera
you know you every every little nuance
like a little everything's picked up I
think it makes it much more real much
much better and it's amazing to me the
games that have that ability don't do it
and they still have someone else do the
motion can you save so they think it's
it's more expensive but by the time you
get somebody here doing the capture and
then you're going to try to marry it
doesn't quite work it's it's it's you're
just shooting yourself in the foot
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]